I think this has to be the last one I so
thank you you've gone over it's good to
see you all I can't take selfies with
everyone keep in mind but here's what I
think's going on I want ask the question
in two ways as you may know I'm a white
guy I belong to two unions but I think I
think the problem on both sides is fear
yep
people are afraid people of my ancestry
are afraid of having to pay for
everything when as immigrants come into
this country people who are come in the
people who work at the diner in Alabama
are afraid to try to ask for what is
reasonable so do you have a plan to work
with people in Congress that are afraid
and I think that's what's going on with
many of the conservatives especially
when it comes to climate change people
are just afraid of what will happen if
we try to make these big changes and I
remind everyone article 1 section 8
Clause 8 of the US Constitution refers
to the progress of science and useful
arts so when we address climate change
we're gonna have clean water access to
the Internet and renewable electricity
for everyone on earth let's go
[Applause]
this is amazing so I think one of the
the keys to dismantling fear is
dismantling zero a zero-sum mentality so
that I think is a really important part
of dismantling fear so what does that
mean it means the rejection outright of
the logic that says someone else's gain
necessitates my loss and that my game
must miss necessitate someone else's
lost that my gain must come at the cost
of another person we are increasing our
our capacities for productivity and so
there is we can give without a take is
where we're going through
technologically and we say you know this
idea of how you're going to pay for it
this idea that that there is a person
that pays that pays for it instead of
you know reviewing reviewing progress as
a cost instead of as an investment and
investments the difference between a
cost and investment is that an
investment yields returns and when we
choose to invest in our systems we are
choosing to create wealth we are
choosing to create wealth and we invest
in when we all invest in them then the
wealth gets them the wealth is is for
all of us to and so I think part of
dismantling the fear is dismantling a
zero-sum mentality but you know it's not
it's not just about like this idea of
who are our decision-makers it's that we
like this is us this is about voting
this is about the conversations that
were having with our elected officials
because I go there and whether it's true
or not they blame all of it on you guys
they do I go and I'm frustrated and I'll
say why are you why did you weaken
this environmental thing and they say my
community doesn't want that it's my
district you know man like it's my
district and no one else like knows what
anyone else's community is like so
they're like oh wow that's weird okay
and and because no like I'm to this day
I've never heard a person person
actually like level with me and be like
listen my main donors are fossil fuel
people and I just can't no but even in
like the candor of an honest
conversation no-one's no one has said
that to me no one has ever said to me
listen you know I've got these really
big donors and to be really honest with
you this is why I can't do that
but we all know it that's what's
happening and and everyone blames it on
their on their electorate and when our
electorate isn't speaking up then
they're allowed to get away with that
but when we decide to participate in
this system and what I talk about is not
just in the on season which is election
time but when we raucous Lee participate
in our system in the off season in the
governance time when we participate in
our own self-governance
not just our own elections but our own
governance when we see what bills are
coming to the floor we show it to the
gallery in DC when we when we pick up
the phone and call our congressmen as
much as we call our local you know
Chinese spot for takeout like that's the
kind of relationship we need to have
because once we start getting vocal they
can't get away with the excuse of my
district doesn't want that anymore
[Applause]
and one last thing about fear you know
is I want to talk one thing you know and
in contrast to fear is is to tell you
something about courage because the
thing about courage is that courage is
self-propagating courage begets courage
so the first person who stands up has to
encounter the most amount of fear and
discomfort but once that one person
stands up it becomes immensely easier
for the second person than the third and
the fourth until it doesn't take any
courage at all to stand up for something
or to do something and so what I would
say is that the biggest antidote to fear
is to when you see someone that is being
fearful is to choose to be the person
that is courageous to show other people
what courage looks like to be the first
person in the room to say that's not
right or to be the person in the room
you know when when you're there's this
conversation and the conversation start
to get taken over with fear-mongering
with like Venezuela this and this and
whatever is to say you know what like
the thing about fear is that it's it's
all designed to get you to run away from
something and it's not a plan fear is
not a plan and but courage is a plan
courage is this is what we're gonna do
this is where we're gonna go this is
what I'm going to stand up and this is
the action that I'm going to take
courage is about our future and fear is
just about anxiety and if you're sick
and tired of being an anxious nation
then you have to just be rejecting fear
outright we can't allow ourselves to be
governed by fear anymore we can't allow
ourselves to be governed by that kind of
rationale to say I'm not gonna allow
fear to control me anymore I am going to
stand up and do the courageous thing
that's a great note to go
[Applause]